es geht ja also Phänomen wie die prepper
zum Beispiel was ich auf der
Weltuntergang vorbereitet und zwar sehr
real den Händen einen wunderschönen
Bilder was das alles braucht Messer und
zur notverrat genau und auch
monatelangezogen
was was steckt oder
[Musik]
Klimakrise angstformer Atomkraft
Kurzform Untergang Meinert man über
Apokalypse und woher eigentlich die der
Gedanke und die Sehnsucht und Barbara
Lebensform das Tier real,-
was Hinterhaupt Ursachen artificial
intelligence Künstler Intelligenz
ja genau
natürlich
also in erster Linie
werden müssen unterwegs
nicht Sorgen bezüglich dem ich finde es
eigenartig dass man mit dem Klimawandel
mit deiner Angst Naivität verbunden ist
genau ich glaube sie schienen umgekehrt
sich nicht so gemacht
aber es geht trotzdem Faszination von
Mensch am Untergang angefangen
extrem ausgeklügelt dargestellt wird was
wie schrecklich das wird sie und ich
muss ehrlich sagen
und all die Sachen Luke das wahnsinnig
gern und interessante aber was ist
eigentlich ja genau
Freund feinschema du weißt ganz genau
wir Menschen haben die gute Gründe das
hat Aliens ganz böse Moral fern und der
Mensch behauptet sich guten
Mönchengladbach
[Gelächter]
abgeräumt ja ja aber das ist sicher
glaube
ich schwarz weiß und es steht ein
bisschen spielt
dieser Mensch wo im Moment muss
auseinandersetzen das Bedrohung
bedrohungslag ist die wohl mehr
geschaffen
und Klimakrise ist äußerst mir selber
sind äußert und das ist schwer zu
haushalten ich glaube es ist nur
narzisstische Fantasie dahinter
passiert und darum der Gedanke also
Stichwort die apokalyptische
Zivilisation
eine große Ereignis aber andererseits
vielleicht auch den Plastik es ist
endlich mal fertig warum spielt man
eigentlich mit dem Wald untergegangen
und die Valley richtig gespielt mit der
mit dass da geht es ja einerseits das
Aussterben ist
goldunder und wir wandern darüber
überleben oder sozusagen
[Musik]
interessant oder zwei Mal ist quasi ist
Aussterben im Zentrum von der
politischen Bewegung aber ganz anders
[Gelächter]
braucht
Fahrrad genau
sehr interessant als Phänomen mal
darüber
was was steckt doch noch dahin kann man
mit dem mit dem Reinhold messgespräch
führt mit dem mit dem Bergsteiger
unmenschliche Zivilisation
Kindergeld auf der nachbusige
harbonisierstoffen und der Ex hat der
Kontrolle und Sicherheit und
selbstmächtigkeit also das erweisen
die innere Stärke ja und ich glaube das
ist doch hochinteressant Motiv in
heutiger Welt mit dem sicherheitsbewusst
sie mit der Gesundheitsdiktatur
und ich bin nicht blöd ich so gefuhr und
das hat für mich schon bist Du
schwarze Haare rausgehen genau
im Schwarzwald
Co mit vier Platz und zwar darf ich die
mitgenommen
vom vom Sünder wo umkehrt und Busse tut
damit paratisch wenn denn die große
Schlacht auffordert
und ich glaube das ist nicht
meistens das
Universum Problem also die versteckt in
detail und so die Waage sind auch noch
einen Erlösung noch einmal Zustand was
die all die Probleme geht ich glaube das
nicht ohne Grund oder so dass die Utopia
naturisch war gesehen und wenn es
konkret werden
seit um
zum Teil besser dass du disturbieren
nein nicht unbedingt was verliert genau
passiert
genau
das erinnert mich an eine Idee vom
Walter Benjamin wo geschrieben
die eigentliche Katastrophe ist fertig
ist sondern dass es wieder Gott wie
bisher das ist Katastrophe inspiriert
aber interessant ist fast auf die
heutige Situation vielleicht sagen
Katastrophen ist ausreichend
Alternative finden
kapitalistischer Waldwirtschaft zum
Beispiel wir haben hier keine wirkliche
Alternative so Tina Prinzip mäßig der
ist normal alternativ man hat keine Idee
das ist fatale ein Umkehrung
wäre aber nicht skizzieren sondern was
man alles werden und das ist doch
im amerikanischer Schriftsteller wir
sind das Klima und ich kann mit dem
normalen Sternschnuppen gemacht und
erzählt einfach auf was alles so
großartig ist also der jetzige
lebensweiss und was er findet was so
schade wäre wenn zu Menschheit wird
aussterben und sind so ganz
Papier oder Landkarten auseinanderfalten
und Landkarte lassen also gute Sachen
und derzeit die Truhe darüber was könnte
weggehen Motor geht die schöne Bilder
sind motivieren nicht die schreckliche
Vorschlag vom Harald Welzel dem
Sozialpsychologe
Utopia
konkreten machen und ich glaube schon
dass faltige Zeit zu beziehen machbares
praktikumswohnung gemacht das das wären
Form okay so Zustand ist glaube wo
nachhaltig ist das nicht einfach so die
überwältigen die das schuldbewusst sie
ist und die Ohnmacht sondern dass du es
handlungswunsch und einfach mal
nicht perfekt und es geht auch ihre
Klinik Community oder mit der Gott mit
dir zieht ich glaube das ist schon der
Weg und dass das Appetit kommt mit dem
Essen das sozusagen mit dem machen
das das oben macht gefühlt weg und die
Angst geht weg indem du sozusagen
vor Politik das wird kein Werk darauf
hat global Strategie findet das sind die
kleinen Projekte die sind Höchststand
es langt nicht und Politik rechts
langsam aber man braucht das Tempo mehr
Angst vor dem Wald Untergang in die
Kommentare Sprachreise zum Thema
kollapsodie und andere sehr aktuelle zum
Thema Energie und Klimakrise und werden
verpassen hat abonniert doch der Kanal